c'est très facile
c'est très agréable n'y a pas de
différence vous savez on sort de la
maison le matin donc voir la voiture et
c'est toujours le même homme et c'est
toujours les mêmes problèmes
sauf que sur le plateau il a un peu plus
dur avec moi vous voyez qu avec les
autres acteurs mais vous accepté de
tourner avec le retour dans l'abri
fidèles
oui parce que vous savez à part ça il
n'y avait pas grand monde qui me
demandait tout votre manche de très
content que qui me propose des rôles
mais il est c'est très agréable pour une
actrice d'être avec un homme qui met en
scène parce que ils vous passez une idée
par la tête par exemple ce que je
pourrais mettre un chapeau bleu dans
cette scène crack vous le demandez tout
de suite c'est oui ou non si c'est non
on passe à autre chose tandis que si
c'est par votre mari vous êtes vous ne
vous êtes pas téléphoné pour pas dérangé
et puis finalement c'est un problème ce
chapeau devient problèmes terribles
stéphane audran est ce que vous ne
pensez pas que claude chabrol donne trop
d'importance à ses copains on
n'abandonne jamais trop assez
d'importance à ses côtés voilà il
donnerait pour vous savez quelles sont
ses qualités ses vraies qualités
c'est un homme un honnête homme c'est un
honnête homme et il est intelligent mais
ça c'est tout le monde un peu le connaît
le sais ça fait quelque temps que sa
femme le dise je trouve fort mesdames il
est drôle il est intelligent diffusé il
a du talent on le dira j'avais la flemme
jamais et il est très agréable à vivre
et il n'est pas méchant du tout et si
vous deviez lui reprocher quelque chose
ce serait quoi nous sûrs proches vous
voyez par exemple pour les petites
choses est formidable pour les grandes
choses vous savez quand il arrive un
grand malheur une grande décision très
important d'apprendre
il est fantastique mais pour les petites
choses pour m'aider accroché un tableau
la maison et où je peux attendre des
années et quand il ya quelque chose
il est pour les petites choses il est
épouvantable il vous envoie des fleurs
alors il ne faut jamais cadeau mais j'ai
jamais on n'a jamais tellement fait
cadeau alors et ça ne me gêne pas du
tout qu'ils s'occupent assez de vous
occuper
comment c'est à dire une femme toujours
que son mari soit très attentionné oui
alors là vous savez moi j'aime bien
qu'on me laisse tranquille alors lui
tranquille tout à l'heure je lui ai
demandé quelle était sa définition du
couple pour vous le couple c'est quoi
c'est des gens qui s'entendent bien
ensemble qu'ils ont les mêmes goûts qui
ont envie d'aller au cinéma même moment
dormir au même moment et moi j'aime
j'aime bien manger lui aussi voilà vous
pensez que vous formez un couple heureux
wachovia
je ne sais pas mais moi j'aime bien vous
voyez quand il part pour trois jours
j'ai pas l'impression que je suis tout à
fait entière tout seul oui je suis un
peu là où il est je suis pas tout à fait
comme je suis quand il est là
[Musique]